every minute right now on linkedin
almost 200 people join 9 000 connections
are made almost six people get a job
every minute out of 4 500 applications
that occur every minute and every minute
1 billion linkedin notifications are
sent to your inbox
okay i joke kinda
but you know what's having a moment
right now
linkedin
you're almost hitting two years at
linkedin as ceo happy almost work
anniversary
what is different now at linkedin than
it was two years ago it's been
fascinating to lead the company over the
last couple of years through covid uh
through a great talent reshuffle where
professionals across the world are not
only rethinking where and how they work
but why they work and the whole world is
turning to linkedin these days of course
that's exactly what you'd expect the ceo
of linkedin to say but i have to admit
lately i've also been turning to
linkedin and not because i'm looking for
a new job but because the other social
networks i use have all sorts of issues
i started facebook i run it
and at the end of the day i'm
responsible for what happens here
we weren't expecting any of this when we
created twitter over 12 years ago
linkedin has largely dodged the social
media backlash why do you think that is
what it's all about on linkedin is
connection for opportunity it's about
people who are having conversations
around trying to get a job or trying to
hire trying to learn a new skill maybe
trying to buy or sell a new product
maybe trying to start a new company
basically people act a lot less like a
jerk when they're trying to network for
work or when they're looking for as he
puts it economic opportunity economic
opportunity opportunity opportunity
economic opportunity opportunity so why
linkedin may have long been known as the
most uncool social network it's actually
one of the most civilized and useful
social networks and not only for us old
seasoned professionals
we're seeing a lot of gen z join the
network right now they're much more
interested in portraying themselves
through video
or through a much more robust profile
than maybe older generations so we're
seeing the platform evolved to much more
cater to them so how is the platform
changing to respond to the influx of
younger users
with new features that stand to
modernize and get you using the 18 year
old professional network more the
feature i found the most interesting and
want to see come to other social
networks is a no politics button it
wipes politics news or chatter from your
main feed how does the system decide
what's political through our editorial
team through our semantic classifiers
through what the community tells us they
do or they don't want we're just
constantly trying to figure out the
types of content that make the most
sense for them to see
you guys are testing it right now
small amount of people do you plan to
roll this out more broadly and if so
when yeah absolutely i would love to see
how people use it if they find it
effective if it's helping them better
accomplish what they're trying to
accomplish on linkedin and then if that
makes sense we'll roll it out to more
you can check now to see if you have
this setting go to account preferences
feed preferences there you might see a
toggle asking if you'd like to see
political content in your feed i haven't
seen any political posts in my feed
since enabling it but to be honest i
didn't have a ton to start with in the
coming months you'll also be able to
launch a live audio or video event right
on linkedin think clubhouse and zoom
right in the linkedin app or website
especially through the pandemic we saw a
ton of events that moved on to linkedin
obviously professional events you can't
have in person and a lot of what we're
seeing work on linkedin are things like
career fairs that you couldn't you know
kind of do in person or the small
professional events and webinars you can
now also add video to your profile photo
in the mobile app tap your profile photo
then tap add cover story and you can
introduce yourself with a 30 second
video gen z really wants to be
showcasing themselves through video
first it's not just about filling out
text on their profile it's constantly
sharing what they're doing what they
know how they do it how they know it
through video and just like every other
social network linkedin is trying to
attract creators people who make content
with new tools that let you reach bigger
audiences on linkedin but roslansky says
it's more than just sharing to go viral
oftentimes
you know you think about creation for
entertainment's sake there's also
creation for opportunity which is i have
these things that i want to be able to
teach my network and i'm going to find
an interesting creative way to showcase
that on linkedin is there a compensation
model for creators on linkedin so we've
actually taken a small group of people
where you know kind of compensating them
more than anything for their knowledge
of like hey what are you seeing and
learning across linkedin that we should
take into consideration as we think
about building features for the masses
he's talking about linkedin's creator
accelerator program a 25 million dollar
fund that's going to creators to help
them build their audience on the
platform and finally i couldn't let the
linkedin ceo go without asking about
everyone's top linkedin peeves first is
the linkedin website kind of a mess and
cluttered thank you very much for the
feedback absolutely something we're
working on for the record that's what
linkedin told me in 2016 when i
complained about the same thing the next
is a lot of notifications and emails
we really want to put control in the
hands of the members for what they do or
don't want to get notified about you can
literally turn on or off anything that
you want to know about and i think it's
really important to understand that you
have a ton of people right now who are
trying to say hey
anytime a new job is posted on linkedin
that hits these criteria please notify
me immediately you can go into settings
communications and get very specific
about what you do and don't want to be
notified about
and then last spam in messages
so uh again something where you can
always you know decide to turn inmail
off if you want you can decide i only
want to hear from my network and we are
testing a variety of kind of new ui and
relevance models there that are going to
create a much cleaner inbox for people
on linkedin but really how does the ceo
of linkedin celebrate a work anniversary
you know i haven't hit that two-year uh
anniversary yet so i'll let you know i'm
sure you'll be notified when i do with
that anniversary